let's do a quick check in on the popular
vote lead for Hillary Clinton Democratic
presidential candidate Hillary Clinton's
popular vote lead over president-elect
Donald has surpassed the 2.3 million
vote mark we are at about sixty four
point eight one seven million votes for
Hillary Clinton 62 point 51 million
votes for president elect Donald a 2.3
million vote lead now there's one
predictor who says that Hillary
Clinton's lead will ultimately top out
around two and a half million votes
really a pretty nice popular vote win
two solid percentage points exactly in
line by the way with national polling
predictions which also raises questions
about those discrepancies between
pre-election polls and exit polls and
actual results in states like Wisconsin
and Pennsylvania and North Carolina now
Donald Trump claims that he actually won
the popular vote because so many
undocumented immigrants voted of course
there's no evidence of that we debunk
that on Monday I don't want to spend too
much more time on that uh a couple
things I want to go through that I think
are more relevant number one three weeks
after the election how are we still even
counting votes in 2016 America we're
counting them because of absentee
ballots and provisional ballots county
by county state by state different
methods in different places uh and and
that's why and it's weird I agree with
you here's the real issue to discuss the
trumpets every time we talk about this
say you sore losers or if they're
talking to me it's usually you sore jus
loser they like to throw that in if it's
a critique of me or something Trump won
the electoral vote nothing else matters
it does matter in the sense that we have
here the biggest lack of a mandate that
we've seen for a long time Trump will be
President when a nearly record number of
voters voted for his opponent hillary
clinton received more votes than any
presidential candidate in history other
than President Obama so I think that it
does matter Trump won because of a
handful of counties in three states in a
country that rejected him by millions of
votes and that does matter when
Democrats start to get in his way and
when people like Kellyanne Conway take
to Twitter and say
Donald Trump had this landslide victory
had such a big man date yet people
didn't vote to overturn Obamacare gather
civil liberties taken away we don't want
any of that I think that that's actually
one of the more important aspects when
you think about because Pat brought up
Obamacare I'll discuss it hey you want
to repeal Obamacare maybe although now
he said some of the provisions are very
good who knows what he'll do when Trump
wants to repeal Obamacare way more
people voted for the candidate who
wanted to expand Obamacare not get rid
of it most of the provisions in
Obamacare are popular Trump would not be
doing the will of the people Rachel to
start going and saying well we're gonna
repeal Obamacare because I want to have
a mandate actually millions more people
voted for the candidate that wanted to
keep it so I think this is super
important it's kind of reminiscent for
me personally in 2012 when the democrats
won more votes for the house but they
still had the minority the season i
started to think well re gerrymandering
for the to be in favor of the republican
so how do we go forward from that well
as far as the you're you're right but
this this is it what we saw in the 2016
presidential election we've seen for a
long time particularly since the 2010
census at the at the house congressional
level and I mean I know that this is not
hugely exciting but the 2020 census is
coming up and and that and the
redistricting that's going to happen
after is how we deal with that and yes
again the will of the people nationally
in 2012 at the house level was way more
people voted for Democrats to be in the
house yet more Republicans won because
of the way that it's gerrymandered no
doubt about it talk about any of these
stories on our reddit discussion forum
at david pakman.com slash read it will
be back after this with economist
richard wolf gamefly is sort of like
netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offered
calm / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s